The joe rogan experience.
Well,
I'm glad over all the years though,
although all the stupid ideas that have had about arguments in my head,
I've avoided all physical altercations.
I've never had a physical altercation.
I've kid,
I've had situations where,
you know,
a long time ago,
I wish I told this guy that or I wish I told them this,
but the reality is it's way better than I didn't cause then what if he went,
well fuck you.
And then he fucking throws a rock at me and then all of a sudden were two men
biting each other.
You want to get on it?
Go that route.
Wrestling in the street like fucking children.
You know what the fuck is that?
When I was a kid,
my dad came home from work once with a fucking black eye.
My stepdad's business was going,
it was falling apart and at one point she got squirrelly in him and his partner
fucking duked it out.
It's crazy.
Yeah,
he been,
youtube wasn't around then.
You know,
there'd be some sort of security.
So it was like,
Whoa,
aren't you like in your fucking forties?
It's like what is happening here?
It was,
it was disappointing.
Embarrassing.
It was sad.
It was a bunch of different things all at once.
You don't think it was bad ass on any level that your stepdad could still throw
now?
No,
he could.
I think he got his ass kicked.
I'm pretty sure that's embarrassing.
I'm sure.
I'm pretty sure he got sucker punched and then uh,
he hit the guy back.
He punched the guy in the stomach,
but I dunno who punched who first,
but it's just fucking pathetic.
This guy was his friend and this guy used to come over to the house and we used
to,
you know,
we all still have family dinners together.
Like the,
him and his wife would come over the house and was,
this is my dad's partner.
And then all of a sudden they're fucking duking it out at work.
Cause the,
the business fell apart.
It was very,
very straight and come over for dinner again or no,
it was,
they became friends again.
Yeah,
they,
they just,
they stayed friends,
you know,
they just,
they've duked it out as friends and then they stayed friends,
but it was just embarrassing and he was embarrassed to,
he felt like such a fucking idiot.
He came home with a black eye,
you know,
it's like,
what am I dealt with?
Hi Roni man to read,
pick up the friendship.
It'd be easier if I won the fight,
if I lost the fight.
That would be in the back of my,
he went the rematch point.
And you get used to,
when you do Jujitsu a lot,
you get used to getting beat can get,
that's a different thing.
There's someone wanting to fight and then like,
okay,
let's,
let's try these techniques.
It,
you know,
if like what if we had some big argument about we were going to combine our
podcasts and then it just didn't go well and I didn't give you the money for the
microphones and then we duked it out and you somehow lost.
I somehow surprise you and had always feel like one in a million chance.
I somehow caught you.
I would feel way stupid or that we're fighting.
I would feel way stupider than that.
I know,
but you're a martial artist.
I get it.
But just right now
go in peace.
He got Doug's.
It's always worth it.
You wouldn't see me in there and like I got my back turned to get down the
amperage shaking my head.
I'd be like,
what bill?
How can they punched me in the face?
And that Ron Howard look at jackass.
That wouldn't bug you.
Depends on if you really just tooled me up.
Like all of a sudden you just fucking unload like a one to leg kick combination
on me and
hit me with a liver shot and dropped me and uh,
and then I had tap out.
Yeah.
Then I'd
probably want some sort of a rematch.
Let me ask you this,
which really upset would you lose a belt class?
Would you have to go back down to Brown belt and you'll lose?
I mean,
the only way you get to the ideas that you're a certain level of proficiency,
but it doesn't mean that someone can't get you.
What if I started Fluxx helps get tapped all the time.
If my face to your Dojo,
you'd have to lose just when a UTI bill
who's next and I'm just sitting there with a stupid look on my face.
Oh van.
You know,
competition is healthy.
I think it's fun and everything,
but when it gets in the real world,
like as far as like fighting people and shit like that,
it's too spoiled because you don't just fight someone.
They'd get mad and then they come back and they want to bring a baseball bat or
fucking stab you or shoot you.
I never fought outside my family past June,
outside flashy when junior high started getting to be like,
you know,
a buck and a quarter and like new hot becoming coordinated dude.
I saw one kid take a pounding and I was just like,
yeah,
I'm sticking with the jokes.
It was this kid who was,
he was jacked.
He's one of those up man childs,
you know,
and like in like eighth grade,
they art,
they could like beat up the teacher but then they get to high school and they
just stop growing.
And then the,
just this little fireplug but eighth grade that's like the,
that's their peak.
And this kid was at his apex of,
of physical fitness and he was fighting this doughy.
There's baby who we look in kid and they go to get off the bus and baby Hueys
behind Manchild and he just,
you know,
he just pushed him down from behind,
jumped,
got on his chest and it was just,
he just started teeing off on his head and it was one of those,
you know,
when people go crazy and then it becomes disgusting.
Like the crowd was just like,
ah.
And he's just like,
he was just beating the fuck out of him.
He didn't come to school for the rest of the week and he came back the next
week.
And the swelling in his face,
he had come down probably 80% but he misses manchild still didn't look,
and he had a look in his eye.
I remember his confidence was shaken.
I'm,
I,
it was,
it was amazing man.
I was like,
you saw it was a,
it was a moment in his life.
And I remember just looking at that going,
yeah,
yeah.
Have,
it was funny because I almost went out of with that baby.
He would kid,
I would have got killed.
He's like,
he just,
he would have stabbed me with the fucking kid.
No,
he used to get bullied and he just,
I dunno,
he was used to getting the crap kicked out of him by people like two years
older,
which is basic when you're in seventh grade,
like that two years is a huge jump physically.
And it's like you're sitting there,
you know,
like,
okay,
I'm going to find you and the other guys,
like,
we've got like a beard,
you know,
smashing you over the head.
So,
um,
yeah,
so all my fights were basically within my family and I had four brothers,
so I used to practice on my three younger ones and then try to take my older
brother who had the psychological advantage over me.
So older brothers always have an advantage.
I had a friend who's a older brother,
used to beat the fuck out of them and it tortured him late into adulthood.
He was in his late thirties and it was fucked.
It fucked his head
up.
He always wanted to get back at his brother.
He used to go over his brother's house and his brother wasn't home and steal
shit from them.
Like he would go like his wife,
his brother's wife was there.
He'd say hi.
And again I got,
John told me to go pick something up and he'd go in and just steal from his
brother.
What's still kinds of shit?
Beat the fuck out of him.
His brother beat the fuck out of him and his brother was like two years older
and just use to just box him up.
He's to fucking really hurt them and intimidate the shit out of.
I got one for,
I went last time I fought my youngest brother,
uh,
I forget when we went out and about my dad came in to break it up and like a
piece of shit.
I did one more over my dad's shoulder caught him and it made that classic like
Hollywood should have rec recorded the sound for like the punch in the face is
that classic but like with a little bit of lip sound kind of right in the mouth.
And uh,
I knew what bugged them and then what would hit for like 15 years we would be
out drinking.
And like when he got on his third drink,
I would feel him sizing me up.
I felt it,
I felt it.
I was just going,
is this in my head or is this dude sizing me up?
And then like years later I'm drink with my other brother and we were talking
about,
and I'm going,
yeah,
he doesn't think I noticed,
but I feel him size and up.
He goes,
Oh yeah dude.
every time I drink with them,
he brings that and like by then he was a little bit taller than me and he had
that,
that anger and stuff.
But uh,
I just want to,
I want to just tie them up.
Like I got to a point where I just,
you know,
I'll get a strategy planned out in your head.
Don't go to the sucker punch.
Get the clench.
Yeah.
My older brother came at me a bit about 11 years ago and like a red roof inn,
some,
some sort of bullshit and he came flying at me.
You know,
my brother,
no joke.
He can fight and I just tied them up.
I had been,
but I had the advantage where he has a real job,
so he has to work.
I can sit here going on hikes and going to the gym and stuff.
So I was in,
I've cardio,
I was in better shape,
so I just,
I just tied them up.
Hello Jeff.
The time up for not,
not long ago and he was like one of these past 15 seconds.
It's like in cubicle shape.
Like that initial I'm going to,
I'm going to kill you.
But this is the thing though,
if he would have,
if I didn't,
uh,
tie him up.
Yeah,
that's all.
Like,
it's,
it's like in hockey when,
when someone does not have a fight,
they just grabbed the guy and like bear hug them.
I just thought it did that and I was uh,
how was it?
He was kind of on top of me,
but I just,
I just sat,
I'm sorta smothered in there.
I was like,
dude,
I'm not going to fight.
I can fight.
He didn't talk to me for a year.
Wow.
You didn't talk to me for a year.
And what was he mad about?
I don't,
it was,
dude,
it's that family shit.
I Dunno.
Something from 1974.
I'm glad.
I don't know.
I would not want to grow up with someone like me if I was a brother,
if I had be like it,
one or two things would have happened would have been either we would join an
alliance and fucking start a team take on the world and tag team checks or we
would fight to the death.
It's going to be one or the other.
I don't really see any,
the other options.
Yeah,
so which one's going to be fucking,
you know,
I think there's a reason why you didn't have a brother.
Cause I,
whenever I talked to him,
he has like,
you'll have a couple of parakeets and they somehow have a fight to the death.
Like,
dude,
what's with parking?
They just go at it too.
Ah,
freaks and Geeks.
Lovers and children.
What's going on?